>> LAST TIME ON "TOP MODEL"...
>> I'M INCREDIBLY SAD
AND DISAPPOINTED.
>> WELL, YOU WERE HOPING
TO GET A WEAVE?
>> I WANTED LONG,
WAIST-LENGTH HAIR.
>> I AM REALIZING THAT THIS IS
KIND OF LOOKING A LITTLE WEIRD.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> THAT'S NICE.
>> I KIND OF STOOD
IN FRONT OF HER.
I KNOW WHAT I WANT,
SO BETTER KEEP UP.
>> HEY, SARA, STOP ANALYZING.
I CAN SEE IT IN YOUR FACE.
>> COME ON, DOMINIQUE,
GET IN THERE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
IN YOUR HEAD, THOUGH?
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T HAVE
NO THOUGHTS.
>> BUT THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
SARA.
DOMINIQUE WAS SENT HOME.
TEN GIRLS REMAIN,
ALL VYING FOR A CHANCE
TO BE IN ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH, IT'S JUST YOU.
>> I'M CROPPED OUT.
>> IT FEELS AMAZING
HAVING MY PHOTO CALLED FIRST.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> I THINK MY FACE WAS LIKE...
SHOCK.
>> WHAT STANDS OUT
IS A BAD ATTITUDE ON SET,
AND THAT WON'T BE TOLERATED.
>> NO, IT WON'T.
TYRA SAID THAT, YOU KNOW,
BAD ATTITUDE
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED.
IF ANYONE TOOK
MY ATTITUDE WRONGLY,
THAT'S WHERE I WANT
TO REDEEM MYSELF,
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I NEVER
WANT TO COME OFF.
>> I-I WAS GONNA SAY,
EVEN THOUGH SHE HAD A GREAT
PICTURE, I DIDN'T THINK
THEY WOULD GIVE HER TOP PHOTO
BECAUSE OF THE DIVA ATTITUDE
PROBLEM.
>> A TOP MODEL DOESN'T ACT
THE WAY SHE DOES.
>> I WAS HOPING SHE WOULD
GO HOME, NOT GET TOP PHOTO.
I'VE BEEN MODELING FOR, LIKE,
A LONG TIME NOW--THREE YEARS.
AND I'M A LITTLE UPSET
SHE GOT TOP PHOTO.
JUST THE FACT THAT SHE WAS
UNPROFESSIONAL ON SET...
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE GOT A LITTLE CRANKY.
>> DOES IT HURT?
LET ME SEE.
>> NO. I DON'T EVEN WANT
TO THINK ABOUT MY LIP RIGHT NOW.
>> I DON'T THINK
SHE DESERVED THAT.
BUT I KNOW, I THINK,
EVERYBODY WOULD LOVE
IF SHE GOES HOME NEXT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
AT THE LAST ELIMINATION
WAS
SODEPRESSING.
>> SARA.
>> APPARENTLY,
IT WAS MY CONFIDENCE
AND SELF-DOUBT THAT PUT ME
IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
>> SO TELL ME, WHAT'S THIS DOUBT
THAT YOU HAVE?
>> I'M JUST GONNA HAVE TO
LOOK INSIDE AND TRY
AND FIGURE OUT WHERE IT COMES
FROM AND HOW TO DEAL WITH IT.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M KIND OF A CREEPER--
A FEMINIST.
I'M FROM A POOR BACKGROUND.
I DON'T LOOK LIKE
ALL THE OTHER GIRLS.
I FEEL LIKE I'M LESS OF A WOMAN
IN COMPARISON TO THEM.
SO I HAVE TO SHOW
THAT I BELIEVE IN MYSELF
AS A MODEL,
AND THAT I DO HAVE
THE CONFIDENCE AND SELF-ESTEEM
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> SO WHAT'S YOUR FIRST
PRIORITY, COLLEGE OR MODELING?
>> I HAVE TO GO TO SCHOOL.
I HAVE TO HIT THE GROUND RUNNING
AS SOON AS I GET BACK.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE ALL GONNA BE DOING,
BUT I'M GONNA BE... WORKIN'
SOME... RUNWAYS,
WORKIN' FOR IMG.
WHO ELSE IS WITH ME HERE?
I'M GOING TO NEW YORK
EITHER WAY--I GET IMG OR NOT.
>> WE CAN'T LEAVE OUR FAMILIES
AND GO TO NEW YORK.
LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO START SMALL
IF THIS DOESN'T WORK OUT.
THIS WAS A BIG HOPE
AND A PRAYER.
ALEXANDRIA--
SHE'LL MAKE SNARKY COMMENTS.
SHE'S QUESTIONING MY--MY PURPOSE
AND MY PASSION FOR MODELING.
SHE'S QUESTIONING
MY WHOLE REASON FOR BEING HERE.
WHEN OUR LOOKS RUN OUT,
I NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT ONCE THIS IS DONE,
I CAN BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
PROVIDE FOR THE PEOPLE I LOVE.
>> YEAH, DUDE, BECAUSE, LIKE--
>> I FEEL THAT SARA FEELS
LIKE SHE CAN'T GO TO NEW YORK
RIGHT AFTER THIS.
BUT I'M NOT GOING BACK
TO ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS IS MY DREAM.
THE GIRLS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT GOING BACK TO SCHOOL?
(scoffs)
NEW YORK, HERE I COME.
IT'S ABOUT BEING A SUPERMODEL.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> LET'S DO THIS.
>> "IF YOU DON'T WATCH
YOUR STEP, YOUR CAREER
WILL GO UP IN FLAMES.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO A FIRE STATION,
AND WE GET TO WALK UP STEPS
AND WE GET TO CARRY HOSES.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SEE
THE FIREMEN?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> YES, I DO!
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HELLO.
>> IT'S CLEAR WHY YOU'RE HERE.
>> YES.
>> IN TONIGHT'S
RUNWAY CHALLENGE,
YOU WILL BE MODELING
THE LATEST COLLECTION
FROM GEOFFREY MAC,
WHO HAS DESIGNED FOR ONE OF
OUR TOP CELEBRITIES TO DATE--
LADY GAGA.
>> AAH!
>> GEOFFREY MAC
DESIGNS FOR LADY GAGA.
I THINK HE'S FIERCE.
I HAVE THE STRONGEST
RUNWAY WALK, AND I GOT THIS.
>> THIS COMPETITION
IS REALLY HEATING UP,
SO LOOK ALIVE, LADIES.
I WANNA SEE YOU LIGHT UP
WITH BURNING DESIRE
TO COME OUT ON TOP,
TO HELP YOU IGNITE THAT FLAME.
(fire whooshes)
>> OH!
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT'S LIKE...
FLAMES RISING.
WHAT THE HELL
IS THE POINT OF THIS?
LIKE, THIS IS SO CRAZY.
>> AND WE'RE LIKE,
UM, I DON'T KNOW
HOW THAT'S QUITE GONNA WORK
WITHOUT US DYING.
>> BETTER MAKE SURE
YOU OUTSHINE THOSE FLAMES.
BUT THERE'S ONE MORE THING.
DID I HAPPEN TO MENTION
THAT WE'LL ALSO BE
LIGHTING YOUON FIRE TONIGHT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU WILL BE WALKING
WITH YOUR HANDS
ACTUALLY ON FIRE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE
HOLDING FLAMES IN OUR HANDS.
THAT'S CRAZY.
I'M STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT
WITH MY WALK,
AND DALYA ALSO HAS
A VERY COMPOSED WALK.
I DEFINITELY NEED
TO BRING MY A-GAME.
>> THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
TONIGHT WILL GET TWO DRESSES
FROM THE GEOFFREY MAC
2011 COLLECTION.
ONE MORE THING--
OFF TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
A REALLY SUPER-SMOKY EYE.
>> I AM TAKING
YOUR EXTENSIONS OUT.
>> MY WEAVE WAS CRAZY.
I'M JUST HAPPY THAT TYRA
IS GOING TO GET THIS WEAVE
OUT OF MY HEAD.
>> IT'S A WEAVE MALFUNCTION,
BUT WE'LL HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT.
>> HOLD THAT.
(giggles)
>> IT HAD TO BE TAKEN OUT.
AND I THINK THEY'RE PROBABLY
GONNA REDO IT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, NOT FOR TONIGHT.
>> (gasps)
IT'S OUT!
>> UGH!
I LOOK CRAZY.
>> I LOVE THIS DRESS.
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE PERFECT
FOR YOUR FIGURE.
>> AND YOU CAN'T SEE THE BRA?
>> NO.
>> I AM NERVOUS
ABOUT THE CHALLENGE.
THE WORST THING
THAT COULD HAPPEN IS THAT
I COULD POSSIBLY GET, LIKE,
A THIRD-DEGREE BURN.
>> SLOWLY SLIDE IN.
>> I DO HAVE A BIT OF HAIRSPRAY,
AND I DON'T WANT MY CLOTHES
TO CATCH ON FIRE,
SO THAT'S FREAKY.
>> ONE, TWO, THREE.
>> WHAT IF I, YOU KNOW,
GET DISFIGURED AND THIS--
AND I WANNA BECOME A HAND MODEL?
I FEEL A LITTLE NERVOUS.
I'VE NEVER WALKED DOWN A RUNWAY,
LET ALONE ON FIRE,
AND I'M TRYING NOT
TO... MY PANTS.
>> NOW WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU FALL?
>> OH.
>> YOU'RE DEAD.
>> IF YOU FALL...
>> STOP, DROP, AND ROLL?
>> I SAY CLAP YOUR HANDS
TO PUT OUT YOUR FIRE,
GET THE HELL OFF.
>> I'M SCARED.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WELCOME TO THE GEOFFREY MAC
FASHION SHOW.
IT'S GONNA BE REAL...
SSS!HOT.
ENJOY.
(cheering)
(fire roars)
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OH, MY LORD.
ARE YOU KIDDIN' ME?
(flames whooshing)
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THIS IS COMPLETELY CRAZY.
I'M SO SCARED ABOUT THE FIRE.
(whoosh)
>> I'M GONNA GO UP IN FLAMES.
(cheering)
(flames roar)
>> OH, MY GOD.
(whooshing)
>> I'M SCARED.
I'M OPENING THE SHOW.
I AM THE GUINEA PIG.
>> REMEMBER, PASS YOUR HANDS
OVER THE FLAMES...
>> YES, SIR.
>> AND THEN LEAVE 'EM FLAT.
BUT I NEED TO WIN
THIS CHALLENGE.
SO I'M REALLY, REALLY EXCITED.
(heartbeat thumping)
(flames roar)
(cheering)
>> ALEXANDRIA--
FOR SOME REASON, ALEXANDRIA CAN
LOOK A LITTLE BIT ROUGH
ON THE EDGES, BUT I THOUGHT
SHE HELD HER OWN TODAY.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS
REALLY, REALLY GREAT.
(cheers and applause)
>> THAT WAS... SO SICK!
I WANNA DO IT AGAIN!
>> I JUST LOVE FIRE.
I WAS ABSOLUTELY ECSTATIC.
AND AS SOON AS I LIT MY HANDS
ON FIRE, I WAS, LIKE,
THE QUEEN OF FIRE OR SOMETHING.
>> BRITTANI--
SHE WAS STRONG COMPETITION.
BUT I REALLY FEEL LIKE
I HAVE A GOOD CHANCE.
I WAS BORN TO DO THIS.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> YOU'RE GOOD.
>> I'M REALLY EXCITED.
I WAS KIND OF
A SLIGHT PYROMANIAC
WHEN I WAS LITTLE.
I MEAN, I WASN'T REALLY WORRIED.
THAT WAS BADASS!
>> AAH!
I'M SCARED WAITING FOR THE CUE
BACKSTAGE TO GO.
AND THEN I GO, AND I'M TRYING
TO LIGHT MYSELF ON FIRE.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S A--
USUALLY, THAT'S A GOOD THING--
YOU HAVE TROUBLE
LIGHTING YOURSELF ON FIRE.
>> OH, SARA.
UM, I LOVE SARA,
BUT SHE WAS KIND OF A HOT MESS.
HER RUNWAY WALK WAS NOT GOOD.
WHOA, WHEN I STEP OUT
ONTO THAT RUNWAY, I JUST, LIKE,
FELT REALLY EMPOWERED.
LIKE, IT'S AWESOME.
>> KASIA HAS THIS HABIT
THAT THEY NEED TO BE EXTRA SEXY,
AND IT'S ALWAYS IN THE MOUTH,
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY.
>> WHEN I GOT UP ON THE RUNWAY,
I WAS PUMPING MYSELF UP.
THERE WAS NO STOPPING ME,
'CAUSE I LOVE RUNWAY, PERIOD.
>> DALYA--
SHE LOOKED REALLY, REALLY GREAT,
SHE LOOKED
REALLY, REALLY ELEGANT.
SHE WAS VERY, VERY FOCUSED.
(cheering)
(flames roar)
>> WHOO!
>> OKAY, GIRLS.
WE HAVE A FEW HITS
AND A FEW MISSES.
SARA, YOU HAD TROUBLE
GETTING LIT...
AND IT WAS A SLOPPY LIGHTING.
BUT WHEN YOU GOT
YOUR WALK TOGETHER,
YOU WERE A LITTLE BETTER
THAN I EXPECTED.
HANNAH, A LITTLE MORE PRESENCE
FROM YOU,
'CAUSE YOU SEEMED... JUST LOST.
KASIA, YOU HAVE GOT
TO GET OUT OF THIS...
>> (laughs)
>> IT'S JUST A BIT
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
BUT I HAVE THREE GIRLS
WHO I THOUGHT
WERE NECK AND NECK--
ALEXANDRIA,
BRITTANI,
DALYA.
YOU WERE THE THREE GIRLS
WHO HELD YOUR OWN.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE BRILLIANT.
AND THE WINNER WAS...
DALYA.
>> YES!
OH, MY GOD.
>> YOU LOOKED REALLY,
REALLY GOOD.
YOU LOOKED VERY ELEGANT,
AND YOU HELD IT TOGETHER.
SO YOU GET TWO DRESSES FROM
THE GEOFFREY MAC COLLECTION.
>> THIS IS EXCITING.
I FEEL, LIKE,
ON TOP OF THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
I GOT TO PROVE MYSELF OUT THERE.
'CAUSE I KNOW I'M A REALLY
STRONG WALKER,
SO I GOT TO PROVE MYSELF,
AND I FEEL AMAZING RIGHT NOW.
>> FOR THE THREE GIRLS
WHO WEREN'T SO GREAT,
YOU NEED TO PRACTICE YOUR WALKS
A LITTLE BIT MORE...
AND YOU CAN DO THAT
BY WALKING HOME TONIGHT.
>> WHAT?
>> YES, YOU'RE WALKING HOME
TONIGHT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> SO, GIRLS...
BYE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I AM SHOCKED.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WAS SERIOUS
WHEN HE TOLD US,
"OH, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO WALK HOME, 'CAUSE YOU NEED
SO MUCH PRACTICE."
BUT, NO, WE FIND OUT
WE REALLY DOHAVE TO WALK HOME.
>> I BET YOU THEY'RE ALL
LAUGHING AT HOME.
I'M JUST PISSED.
>> YES.
>> AT FIRST, LIKE, WHEN I WAS
WALKING WITH SARA AND KASIA,
IT WAS A LITTLE UPSETTING.
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN, LIKE,
A REALLY GHETTO AREA.
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
GIVE ME SOME BRASS KNUCKLES
AND PEPPER SPRAY.
>> I WANNA PUT MY HEELS BACK ON.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE I NEED
TO PRACTICE MY WALK.
>> TO PRACTICE.
>> I'M A PROFESSIONAL.
I'M HARDER ON MYSELF
THAN ANYBODY ELSE CAN BE,
SO I'M LIKE, OKAY,
IF THEY THINK, YOU KNOW,
GREAT--YOU NEED PRACTICE,
YOU NEED TO WALK HOME?
OKAY, I'M GONNA DO IT.
>> OKAY, READY, SET, GO.
>> THE WEARY TRAVELERS ARE HOME!
>> WE PUT OUR HEELS ON
TO PRACTICE.
ALL I'M GONNA BE DOING ALL NIGHT
IS PRACTICING MY WALK.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> WHOA!
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> WAIT, DO WE HAVE EVERYBODY?
>> "TOMORROW, IT'S OKAY
FOR YOU TO CAUSE A SCENE.
LOVE, TYRA."
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO ACT TOMORROW,
AND I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT.
HOOEY.
(doorbell rings)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AAH!
IT'S TYRA MAIL!
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> TANGIBLE TYRA MAIL.
>> OPEN IT! OPEN IT!
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> OH.
"MAKE SURE YOU KNOW
ALL THESE LINES BY TOMORROW!"
>> SHUT UP!
>> (British accent) HOW THE HECK
DO YOU MAKE COFFEE SEXY?
(normal voice) WE GOT
THE SCRIPT,
AND IT WAS A COMMERCIAL
FOR FIERCE ROAST COFFEE.
"A MAN SITS BEHIND HIS DESK
HOLDING UP A JAR OF COFFEE,
STARING AT IT.
HE LOOKS PANICKED.
JANICE AND GLORIA,
TWO SECRETARIES, SIT IN
THE OFFICE, LOOKING BORED."
HE'S SAYING THIS--
LIKE, HOW DO I MAKE COFFEE--
A COFFEE COMMERCIAL SEXY?
AND THEN THESE TWO HOT BITCHES
GO OVER TO IT AND SAY,
"MMM. DOESN'T THE FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?"
>> (together) "ANY IDEAS?"
>> OOH.
THERE WAS A LOT OF, LIKE,
SEXUAL INNUENDOS.
>> I'M STUCK!
HOW THE HECK
DO YOU MAKE COFFEE SEXY?
>> "DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?"
>> THAT SOUNDS REALLY SEXUAL.
>> I FEEL LIKE I'M GONNA BE
MR. DRYSDALE,
BECAUSE I CAN'T BE A SEXY WOMAN.
I GLANCED AT THE SCRIPT
WITH MOLLY,
AND I WAS REALLY, LIKE,
UNCOMFORTABLE READING IT.
IT LASTS FOUR TIMES LONGER.
BEING A FEMINIST,
MY WHOLE LIFE, I'VE JUST BEEN
TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM
THE STEREOTYPICAL QUIET,
SUBSERVIENT, DOCILE WOMAN.
NOW TO PUT MYSELF BACK
IN THAT SITUATION AND ACTUALLY
WORK TO FILL THAT ROLE
IS A LITTLE BIT
OF A WORRIED ISSUE FOR ME.
IF A GUY DID THIS,
IT'D BE SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HELLO, DARLINGS.
HEY, GUYS.
>> HI.
>> HOW YA DOIN'?
>> GOOD.
>> WELCOME BACK
TO SMASHBOX STUDIOS.
AND AS YOU GUYS KNOW
FROM YOUR SCRIPTS,
YOU'RE DOING A COMMERCIAL
FOR FIERCE ROAST COFFEE.
AND I'M LOOKING FOR YOU TO BE
FLIRTY, FUN, AND SEDUCTIVE.
AND YOU'RE GONNA LIKE
THE STYLING.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SET
BEHIND ME--VERY RETRO,
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY CURRENT
IN FASHION RIGHT NOW,
WHICH ONLY MAKES SENSE.
FOR YOUR DIRECTOR TODAY,
WE HAD TO GET
A HIGHLY ACCOMPLISHED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
HE HAS SHOT THE COVERS
OF GERMAN "VOGUE,"
"ROLLING STONE,"
"VANITY FAIR."
LET ME INTRODUCE YOU GUYS
TO MR. FRANCESCO CARROZZINI.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> HI, GIRLS.
I HOPE YOU LEARNED YOUR LINES.
>> FRANCESCO CARROZZINI
IS DIRECTING US.
I HAVE A LITTLE CRUSH ON HIM.
HE'S REALLY HOT.
AND HE'S JUST--HE'S AN AWESOME
PHOTOGRAPHER AND DIRECTOR.
>> SO JUST LIKE
IN A PHOTO SHOOT,
THE PERFORMANCE
IN FRONT OF A MOTION CAMERA
IS SO IMPORTANT, OKAY?
AND REMEMBER, MODELS AREN'T
EXPECTED TO JUST TAKE
"PRETTY PICTURES."
A TOP MODEL CAN ALSO
DELIVER LINES IN A COMMERCIAL.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
PAIR YOU GUYS OFF
AS THE TWO SECRETARIES, OKAY?
SO LET'S GET YOU GUYS
INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
'CAUSE THERE'S A LOT
TO DO TODAY, AND WE'VE GOT
FIVE COMMERCIALS TO DO.
SO WE'LL START.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> COOL.
>> YOU'RE LIKE OUR DORIS DAY
FOR THE DAY.
SHE WAS LIKE
THE "MILK AND COOKIES"
OF THAT ERA.
>> SO WE'RE GONNA DO
A COMMERCIAL FOR FIERCE ROAST.
AND THIS IS KIND OF '50s-STYLE,
"MAD MEN" OFFICE
WHERE THE WOMEN ARE SUPPRESSED,
AND THEY CAN ONLY REALLY
USE THEIR SEXUALITY
TO GET IDEAS ACROSS.
>> WE WINK AT EACH OTHER
AT THE END--WE GO...
>> BUT YOU HAVE TO--YEAH,
YOU HAVE TO DO IT LIKE THAT.
NOT CHEESY.
>> NOT...
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
WE'LL BE GOOD.
>> (giggles)
>> BRITTANI WAS MY PARTNER.
IT'S A PERFECT COMBINATION.
YOU KNOW, SHE'S A VERY STRONG
COMPETITOR, AND I KNOW
THAT I AM AS WELL.
>> YOU GUYS LOOK REALLY,
REALLY COOL,
AND I JUST LOOK SHORT.
>> NO, YOUR DRESS IS SICK.
MIKAELA IS MY PARTNER,
AND I'M WORRIED
THAT MAYBE WE WILL SUCK,
'CAUSE SHE WAS PART
OF THE BOTTOM THREE
FOR THE LAST PANEL,
AND I WAS BOTTOM TWO.
LOOK--I HAVE SOCKS IN MY BRA,
AND AN EXTRA BRA
ON TOP OF MY BRA SOCK.
>> I'VE ALREADY DONE
A PHOTO SHOOT WITH SARA
THE WEEK BEFORE,
IN OUR DOUBLE SHOT,
AND I JUST DON'T THINK SHE HAS
PICKED UP HER CONFIDENCE ENOUGH.
>> LET ME SEE.
>> IS THIS A FAKE BOOTY?
>> YEAH, IT LOOKS GOOD, WOW.
>> WE'LL FIND OUT.
MAYBE A LITTLE MUCH, THOUGH.
>> YOU HAVE A FAKE BOOTY?
>> I DO.
NOW I'M GONNA WANT TO SHAKE.
I'VE NEVER HAD A BOOTY BEFORE.
>> AAH--JACLYN'S GOT A BOOTY!
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE
EVERYBODY GET THEIR COSTUME.
AND I SEE, LIKE, SOCKS AND STUFF
BEING STUFFED IN,
AND FAKE BOOBS, AND JACLYN HAS
HER LITTLE FAKE BOOTY.
>> AND YOU LIKE THE BOOTY?
>> WE LOVE THE BOOTY.
WE DON'T LIKE IT.
WE LOVEIT.
>> WE LOVE THE BOOTY, OKAY.
>> YES.
>> MINE IS REAL.
>> (laughs)
>> AND OF COURSE, IN THE '60s,
WHEN YOUR BOSS SAYS,
"OH, I'M STUCK," YOU CAN'T SAY,
"WELL, I'VE GOT THE ANSWER."
'CAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR
THAT THE SECRETARY--
THE "FEMALE" SECRETARY--
HAS THE ANSWER.
AND YOU'RE REALLY FEEDING HIM
THE IDEA FOR THE--WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO COME UP WITH.
DO YOU GET IT?
>> MY WHOLE LIFE, I'VE JUST BEEN
TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM
THE STEREOTYPICAL
SUBSERVIENT, DOCILE WOMAN THAT
I'M REALLY EMBARRASSED TO HAVE
MY FEMCORE FRIENDS BACK HOME
SEE THIS.
>> ONCE YOU GIRLS GET OUT,
SO YOU'RE GONNA LAND
RIGHT HERE...
>> HERE, AND POUR THE COFFEE.
>> AND YOU'RE GONNA LAND
RIGHT HERE.
>> I WAS PAIRED WITH ALEXANDRIA
AND I WAS JUST KIND OF LIKE,
PFFT. POOEY.
BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST LIKE ONE DAY
SHE'LL BE REALLY COOL, AND THEN
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
SHE'S LIKE DRAMA BITCH,
JUST CRAZY.
>> QUIET ON THE SET!
>> CAN WE TAKE
THE WHOLE ACTION FROM THE TOP?
>> ROLL VIDEO, ROLL SOUND.
CAMERA, PLEASE, "A" AND "B."
>> A-B MARK.
>> ACTION.
(jazz music playing)
>> I'M STUCK.
HOW THE HECK
DO YOU MAKE COFFEE SEXY?
>> DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST COFFEE
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> (gulps)
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> UH, YES, IT DOES.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> WOW, ALEXANDRIA,
LET'S NOT TAKE IT TOO FAR HERE.
LET'S DO IT.
>> HERE WE GO!
>> CAN YOU USE YOUR LIPS IN
A LITTLE MORE OF A NATURAL WAY?
>> SORRY, I DON'T LIKE COFFEE.
>> 'CAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE DRINKING BAD MEDICINE.
>> IS IT ME SIPPING THE COFFEE
OR IS IT THE LINE THAT'S BAD?
>> THE LINE.
>> COMING INTO THE COMPETITION,
I KNEW THIS WAS GONNA BE
MY WEAK POINT,
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER ACTED
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
THAT'S JUST NOT MY THING.
>> I MEAN YOU LOOKED SO, LIKE,
"I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M DOING THIS."
HEY, I MEAN, YOUR JOB TRULY IS
TO MAKE US LOVE ANYTHING.
'CAUSE YOU DON'T WANT
THE DIRECTOR TO SEE
THAT YOU DON'T LIKE IT.
YOU DON'T WANT THE CLIENT TO SEE
YOU DON'T LIKE IT.
>> (voice breaks) OKAY.
>> OKAY?
>> SORRY.
>> YOU KNOW, TODAY'S PERFORMANCE
AND TODAY ME WORKING SO CLOSELY
WITH BRITTANI
REALLY BROUGHT US TOGETHER
BECAUSE SHE REALIZES THAT
I AM THERE TO HELP.
AND IT WAS KIND OF LIKE
A TEAM EFFORT.
>> I WENT AND I WAS GETTING
MY MAKEUP TOUCHED UP,
AND OF COURSE
ALEXANDRIA HAD TO COME OVER.
>> THAT'S SWEET,
'CAUSE YOU'RE, LIKE,
YOU'RE VERY MOTHERLY.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
>> SHE'S COMING TO CHECK ON HER.
I'M LIKE OH, SHE CAN TAKE
MY JOB, I CAN GO HOME,
'CAUSE I GOT A HEADACHE ANYWAY.
ALEXANDRIA--SHE WAS BUSY
DOING FRANCESCO'S JOB,
SHE WAS DOING MY JOB.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE GOT
A SHOT OF US POURING
THE COFFEE, THOUGH, BEFORE.
>> NO, THE COFFEE'S
ALREADY POURED.
>> SHOULD I JUST HAVE MY HAND,
THOUGH, TAKING IT AWAY
RIGHT THERE?
>> CAN'T DO THAT.
LET'S JUST DO ONE THING.
>> DON'T LOOK BACK OVER HERE,
'CAUSE I'M NOT THERE ANYMORE.
LOOK HERE. LOOK HERE.
>> I KNOW, BUT THEY TOLD ME
TO LOOK BACK.
>> AND THEN SHE'S, LIKE,
CHECKING THE LIGHTING.
I SWEAR THE GAFFERS WERE
ALMOST NERVOUS THAT ALEXANDRIA
WAS CHECKING OUT THE LIGHTS.
>> I WAS REALLY JUST TRYING
TO HELP OUT.
>> I KNOW, BUT IF YOU DO THAT
TO--ON A REAL COMMERCIAL,
THEY'RE GONNA TELL YOU
TO GO--GO HOME.
>> AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
I'M VERY SORRY.
>> YOUR FIGURE IS SO GORGEOUS.
>> NOW MY HIPS LOOK HUGE.
>> AND YOUR BADONKADONK
LOOKS GORGEOUS.
THE TWO GIRL CHARACTERS
ARE REALLY VIXENS, SO REALLY,
WE'RE THE BRAINS
BEHIND THE OPERATION.
SO I THINK IT'S--
I THINK IT'S COOL.
IT'S EMPOWERING
BECAUSE BACK THEN,
WOMEN COULDN'T HAVE ANY SAY,
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY HAD NO RIGHTS TO ANYTHING.
>> ACTION.
FACE GEORGE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL--SORRY.
>> HEY, OKAY, OKAY, CALM DOWN.
WE--WE'RE STILL ROLLING.
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> KASIA--SHE JUST HAS
A REALLY UNIQUE LOOK ABOUT HER.
SHE LOOKED AWESOME.
SHE DID REALLY WELL.
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> CUT.
VERY GOOD, UH, KASIA.
I HAVE NO REAL NOTES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M TEAMED UP WITH DALYA
FOR THE COMMERCIAL.
I LOVE DALYA, SO I WAS
TOTALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
>> ACTION.
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> CUT.
EXCELLENT, VERY GOOD.
YOU TOOK DIRECTIONS VERY WELL.
>> ROLLING.
>> MARK.
>> AND ACTION.
>> MMM, DOESN'T THE FRENCH ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> IT'S FIERCEROAST,
NOT FRENCH ROAST.
>> OH...
I DRINK FRENCH ROAST.
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> TAKE YOUR TIME.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
>> FIERCE ROAST--
FOR WHEN YOU NEED A QUICK
PERK-ME-UP.
>> CUT.
>> NEXT TWO GIRLS IN, PLEASE.
>> ROLL VIDEO, ROLL SOUND!
>> ACTION.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
YOU'RE SHAKING.
>> MY HANDS ARE SHAKING, I KNOW.
>> WHY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S ONLY MY RIGHT HAND.
>> DO IT, DO IT.
>> (singsongy) I AM TRYING.
>> DO IT, DO IT, DO IT.
SAY YOUR LINE.
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> CUT.
GOOD.
>> MARKER.
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> YOU'RE LOOKING AT HIM
WHEN YOU SAY THAT,
'CAUSE YOU HAVE TO SEDUCE HIM,
NOT HER.
>> (laughs)
ALL RIGHT, SORRY.
>> DON'T PUT THE THUMB
IN THE CUP, PLEASE.
IN THE CUP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> CUT.
NOT GOOD.
>> RIGHT NOW IT'S ABOUT AS SEXY
AS WATCHING PAINT DRY.
>> GOTTA FIX MY SEXY.
>> I SAW SARA TRY TO DO
THE COMMERCIAL, AND I THINK
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN MAYBE
PRACTICING SEXY IN THE MIRROR
A LOT MORE.
>> DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> CAN YOU DO IT AGAIN?
SARA--I DON'T KNOW,
SHE ALMOST DIDN'T BELIEVE
IN THE WHOLE THING
FROM THE BEGINNING.
YOU KNOW, IT FELT LIKE SHE READ
THE SCRIPT AND SAID,
"OKAY, THAT'S NOT FOR ME."
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> SARA, WHAT WAS THAT?
>> I'M FINDING IT REALLY HARD
TO FAKE ANY SORT
OF SEXUAL ENERGY AND/OR EMOTION.
I'VE NEVER HAD TO FAKE ANYTHING
LIKE THAT IN MY LIFE.
DOING IT FOR A COMMERCIAL
WAS JUST REALLY DIFFICULT.
>> THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYONE.
GREAT JOB, EXCELLENT!
>> GREAT.
>> WHOO! ALL RIGHT!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (singsongy) I WANT A BATH!
>> I CAN ALREADY TELL YOU
WHAT IT SAYS.
>> COME ON!
>> HURRY UP!
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY NINE WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPE OF BECOMING..."
>> "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> DOESN'T NINE SEEM
REALLY SMALL?
>> IT DOES.
>> ALREADY TO THE SINGLE DIGITS.
>> (imitates British accent)
THE SINGLE DIGITS.
>> I CAN DO IT, BUT I HAVE
TO PRACTICE MORE AT IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE MEANT.
>> WELL, WE'RE NOT ACTRESSES.
WE'RE MODELS.
>> ALEXANDRIA AND I DID NOT
HAVE A GOOD DAY TOGETHER TODAY.
I DIDN'T MEET
MY OWN EXPECTATIONS.
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA DO WELL,
AT LEAST.
LIKE, IT WAS JUST--I REALLY
DISAPPOINTED MYSELF.
I JUST FELT LIKE CRAP.
BUT I'M ABSOLUTELY
NOT READY TO GO HOME.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS LIKE...
"MMM,DOESN'T THIS FIERCE ROAST
COFFEE SMELL DELICIOUS?"
AND THEN I LOOKED AT HER.
YOU KNOW, LIKE, I-I LEANED
ON HER, SHE LEANED ON ME.
>> ALEXANDRIA--SHE'S BOSSY.
SHE'S PUSHY, AND I REALLY HOPE
PANEL SEES THAT,
BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
SHE COULD GET SUCH GOOD FEEDBACK
AND KEEP ON MOVING
IN THE COMPETITION
WHEN SHE HAS
THIS HUGE ATTITUDE PROBLEM.
>> I'M A HORRIBLE ACTRESS.
AND I'M SO FREAKING NERVOUS
ABOUT PANEL.
I DON'T WANNA BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO AGAIN.
THAT'S LIKE THE KISS OF DEATH.
I DON'T WANNA BE TOLD THAT,
"YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH CONFIDENCE."
'CAUSE I THINK, LIKE, HONESTLY,
IF TYRA TELLS ME ONE MORE TIME,
"YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU ARE SO SCARED,"
I'M JUST GONNA BE LIKE, "NO!"
>> OH, NEVER MIND.
HI, HOW ARE YOU?
>> HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
>> NICE TO SEE YOU. CIAO!
>> NICE TO SEE YOU.
IT'S HOT,
AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE HE'S FINE.
IT REALLY IS HOT.
>> HELLO, LOVELY LADIES.
>> HI.
>> I GOT MY WHIP OUTFIT
ON TONIGHT, HONEY.
WHOO! BE SCARED.
WE'LL SEE WHO PREVAILED,
AND WHO FAILED.
ARE WE READY TO START?
>> YES.
>> YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THETOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
AND A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
WHICH IS THE BEAUTY MAGAZINE
FOR ITALIAN "VOGUE,"
AND A SPREAD
IN "BEAUTY IN VOGUE," TOO,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
OUR JUDGES--MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALLOF FASHION HISTORY,
AND OUR GUEST JUDGE,
THE SEXY FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
FRANCESCO CARROZZINI.
HIS WORK APPEARS
IN ITALIAN "VOGUE"
AS WELL AS "VANITY FAIR."
ARE WE READY TO START?
WHERE'S MY WHIP?
(imitates whip cracking)
LET'S GO.
OKAY, SO WE HAD TO BRING
A LITTLE "MAD MEN" SPICE
TO "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WITH '60s RETRO,
SEXY BOMBSHELL FEMALES.
YES, THAT WAS THE COMMERCIAL.
AND FRANCESCO CARROZZINI
WAS YOUR DIRECTOR.
FIRST TWO GIRLS--
MONIQUE AND HANNAH.
YOU GUYS WERE THE SEXY GIRLS
WITH THE IDEAS
IN THE COMMERCIAL?
>> MM-HMM.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THESE.
>> I'M STUCK.
HOW THE HECK
DO YOU MAKE COFFEE SEXY?
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> YES, IT DOES.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
IS EVERYTHING OKAY, SIR?
>> (clears throat)
COULD I HAVE
SOME OF THAT COFFEE?
>> (whispers) FIERCE ROAST--
FOR WHEN YOU NEED
A QUICK PERK-ME-UP.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BRAVO. BRAVO. I-I THINK
YOU BOTH DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
HANNAH, YOUR BODY LANGUAGE,
THE LOOK IN YOUR EYES,
I WAS TOTALLY SOLD.
MONIQUE, I THOUGHT YOU DID
A GOOD JOB AS WELL,
ALTHOUGH I THOUGHT PERHAPS
YOU WERE A LITTLE RESERVED.
>> HANNAH KIND OF FOUND A KEY
FOR HER CHARACTER, WHICH WAS
PLAYING OUT OF THIS NAIVETÉ,
THIS--ALMOST GIRL THAT DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT SHE WAS DOING,
BUT SHE WANTED TO BE SEXY,
AND SHE DIDN'T KNOW HOW
HOW TO DO IT, AND I THOUGHT
THAT WORKED OUT REALLY WELL.
>> I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE
YOU GUYS PUSH IT
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I LIKED YOUR BODY LANGUAGE,
BUT I JUST THINK
A LITTLE BIT MORE...
A LITTLE BIT CHEEKY,
A LITTLE BIT MORE EYE FLASHES.
BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE THE STAR
OF THE COMMERCIAL, NOT THAT MAN.
THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, THANKS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS JACLYN AND KASIA.
COME ON FORWARD, LADIES.
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> UH, YES, IT DOES.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
YOU GUYS KNOCKED IT
OUT THE PARK.
I'M SERIOUS.
LIKE, THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF
MY FAVORITE "TOP MODEL" MOMENTS.
>> DEFINITELY MINE, TOO.
IT WAS REALLY SUPERB.
>> KASIA, THE LOOK
IN YOUR EYES--I WAS TOTALLY
TAKEN IN BY YOU.
>> THE LITTLE HIPS SHAKE,
AND THEN YOU, LIKE, LEANED OVER
ON THE TABLE, JACLYN.
I JUST THOUGHT YOU GUYS
TOOK EVERY LITTLE MOMENT,
AND Y'ALL MILKED IT.
>> I WAS TRYING TO SHAKE
MY FAKE BOOTY.
THEY GAVE ME A FAKE BOOTY
TO PUT ON.
>> THEY PUT A BOOTY
ON YOUR BOOTY?
>> OH, YES THEY DID.
>> SHOW ME HOW YOU SHOOK IT.
TURN AROUND RIGHT NOW.
AND WORK IT, WORK IT, YES.
OOH, YOU JUST DROPPED
YOUR PENCIL.
YEAH, GIRL, WHOO!
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
>> ALEXANDRIA AND BRITTANI.
HERE IS YOUR BEST TAKE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MMM,
DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST COFFEE
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> YES, IT DOES.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> YOU'RE PARTNERS IN CRIME,
AND YOU'VE GOT TO
BE THERE TOGETHER IN THE SHOT.
THAT RELATIONSHIP WASN'T THERE.
BRITTANI,
YOUR FACIAL EXPRESSIONS--
BRILLIANT,
BUT YOU'RE NOT JUST A HEAD.
THIS IS A PERFORMANCE
TOP TO BOTTOM.
>> IT WAS LESS EFFECTIVE
AS KASIA AND JACLYN'S.
BRITTANI'S VOICE
DID NOT COME OFF AS SEXY...
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT I THINK ALEXANDRIA
HELD IT TOGETHER,
BUT BRITTANI DID NOT SUPPORT
AND YOU DID NOT BECOME ONE.
>> YEAH.
>> I FOUND IT INTERESTING,
BRITTANI, BECAUSE I ASSUMED
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE DONE
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
BUT IT WAS VERY WEAK TO ME.
IT WAS JUST KIND OF DRAB.
ALEXANDRIA, I FELT YOURS
WAS ACTUALLY TOO SEXY TO ME.
YOU WERE A SECOND AWAY FROM...
(panting)
THE COFFEE... (moans)
>> ALEXANDRIA WENT UP ON SET
AND DIRECTED HER FRIEND...
(laughs) A LITTLE BIT.
>> I WASN'T TRYING TO DIRECT.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO...
KEEP OUR CHEMISTRY THERE.
>> THAT,
TO A BIG COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR--
THEY'RE GONNA JUST, YOU KNOW,
NOT HIRE YOU AGAIN.
>> OR TELL YOU TO LEAVE.
>> YEAH.
>> "OH, GOOD AFTERNOON.
HAVE A NICE DAY."
>> YEAH.
>> "GET THE OTHER ONE
BACK IN HERE."
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, SARA AND MIKAELA.
HERE IS YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> YES, IT DOES.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> COULD I HAVE
SOME OF THAT COFFEE?
>> SARA, YOU JUST LOST THE PLOT.
I WAS, LIKE, WHAT'S THAT?
I MEAN, I JUST FELT NOTHING.
>> MIKAELA,
IF THIS WERE A PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU WOULD LOOK GENIUS.
AND YOU WERE HAVING
PHOTO MOMENTS
HERE, THERE, AND EVERYWHERE.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
IT WAS A COMMERCIAL.
AND ACTUALLY,
I FELT THAT YOU FELL FLAT.
>> SARA, YOU DIDN'T FEEL
INTO THIS COMMERCIAL.
I THINK YOU WERE NOT THERE
AT ALL.
AND I--IT WAS HARD
TO DIRECT YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
DALYA AND MOLLY.
AND WE GON'
GET THAT WEAVE STRAIGHT.
IT'S ALMOST THERE, GIRL.
JUST A LITTLE CUT
AND A LITTLE LOWLIGHTS IN THERE.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
SO, DALYA,
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER
ON THE RUNWAY...
>> I WAS.
>> ON FIRE. CONGRATULATIONS.
(applause)
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MMM, DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> DOESN'T THE BOLD TASTE
LAST FOUR TIMES LONGER THAN
ANY OTHER COFFEE ON THE MARKET?
>> (laughing)
>> YES, IT DOES.
>> ANY IDEAS?
>> MR. DRYSDALE,
ARE YOU OKAY, SIR?
>> DALYA, IT'S ABOUT GETTING
TO "A" TO "B."
THE "A" TO "B" PART DIDN'T WORK.
>> ARE YOU SAYING "A-B"
GETTING OFF THE SOFA,
GOING TO THE COFFEE?
>> YEAH,
THIS GETTING FROM "A" TO "B,"
THE LOCOMOTION PART
JUST WASN'T REALLY WORKING,
WHICH IS SURPRISING 'CAUSE I--
YOU ACTUALLY WON
THE RUNWAY CHALLENGE.
>> MOLLY, AT MOMENTS
THINGS WERE WORKING FOR YOU,
AND THEN AT OTHER MOMENTS,
YOU FELT KIND OF LOST.
>> YOU HAVE SUCH A STUNNING,
INTERESTING FACE,
AND WITH THAT CLOSE-UP,
THAT IS YOUR MOMENT
THAT YOU MILK.
SO YOU--YOU SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN THAT
AND POPPED THOSE EYES UP.
THANK YOU, LADIES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (coquettish voice) IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE...
(whispers) WHICH ONE OF THEM
IS ELIMINATED.
(laughter)
>> CAN I HAVE
SOME OF THAT COFFEE, PLEASE?
>> SEE YA IN A SEC.
>> IT'S TIME TO DELIBERATE,
AND SOMEONE MUST GO HOME, ANDRÉ.
>> SOMEONE MUST GO HOME.
>> WHO IS IT GOING TO BE?
MONIQUE.
>> SHE GAVE THE LOOK.
SHE WASN'T THE BEST,
BUT I THINK SHE PULLED THROUGH.
>> MONIQUE LOOKS AMAZING,
AND--AND IN PERSON, I THINK
SHE'S JUST REALLY IMPROVED.
>> NOT ENOUGH FOR ME.
THE WAY SHE HANDS THE--
YOU KNOW,
SHE WAS HOLDING THE CUP,
AND HER GESTURES
JUST FELT CONTRIVED.
>> HANNAH.
>> HANNAH REALLY EPITOMIZED
NOT JUST THE LOOK
BUT SHE HAD THE BODY LANGUAGE.
SHE WAS FLIRTING.
SHE WAS VERY PRESENT.
>> HANNAH--ONE OF
THE TWO BEST PERFORMANCES.
>> KASIA.
>> SHE TOOK DIRECTION
REALLY WELL.
SHE WAS ON TO BE THE BEST,
AND TO ME, SHE WAS.
>> SHE, FOR ME,
IS EXTRAORDINARY HERE
BECAUSE SHE DEFINITELY
HIT IT OUT THE BALLPARK.
IT'S AMAZING WHAT SHE BECAME
IN THIS COMMERCIAL.
>> KASIA MILKED EVERY SECOND...
>> E-EVERY SECOND
IT WAS HER MOMENT.
>> AND DIDN'T GO OVER-THE-TOP.
>> NEVER.
>> JACLYN.
>> LITTLE JACLYN GAVE ME
THAT LITTLE NAIVE LIBERAL
FROM MASSACHUSETTS.
JACLYN IS STRONG IN MANY WAYS.
>> (high-pitched voice)
HER LITTLE HIGH VOICE...
>> (high-pitched voice) IT DID!
>> IT JUST WORKED PERFECTLY,
HONEY.
(normal voice) I WAS LIKE,
OH, WOW! THIS IS--
SHE'S MADE FOR THIS COMMERCIAL.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> WEAK! BORING. BLAH.
>> NO MATTER HOW WONDERFUL
ALEXANDRIA'S SMALL MOMENTS ARE,
THE ARROGANCE ON SET...
AND THEN EVEN TO DEFEND HERSELF
IN FRONT OF YOU, NOT TO SAY,
"YES, I'M SORRY. YOU'RE RIGHT,"
BUT TO ACTUALLY SAY,
"OH, BUT I DIDN'T--
I DID THIS. I DID THAT."
>> IT'S A DANGEROUS ATTITUDE,
THE ONE SHE HAS.
>> MM-HMM.
>> OOH!
>> YOU'RE A MODEL.
YOU'RE AN ACTOR.
WHATEVER YOU ARE,
THERE'S A PLACE FOR YOU.
CAN'T CROSS THAT LINE.
>> BRITTANI.
>> IT WAS WEAK, BUT I THINK
THAT SHE HAS SUCH POTENTIAL.
AND I DON'T THINK BRITTANI, UH,
WENT DOWN ON THE SHIP.
>> I THINK BRITTANI WANTED
TO DISAPPEAR IN THIS COMMERCIAL.
>> MM-HMM.
>> I THINK SHE WAS LIKE,
"I'M NOT COMFORTABLE.
OH, MY GOSH.
LET ME BLEND WITH THE WALLS."
>> YEAH.
>> SARA.
>> POOR SARA.
>> I THINK THAT SHE THINKS
THAT SHE WAS NOT CAST CORRECTLY
FOR THIS COMMERCIAL.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SHE COULD DEFINITELY
BE THIS GIRL.
SHE'S GOT GREAT LOOKS,
THE GREAT EYES.
THE--THE WHOLE THING COULD WORK.
>> CAM--CAMERA LOVED HER FACE.
>> LOVED HER FACE.
>> IT DID. YEAH.
MIKAELA.
>> HAS SOME GREAT POTENTIAL,
BUT SHE HAS NO AWARENESS
OF HER BODY.
>> I WANNA SHAKE HER.
THERE'S SOMETHING IN THERE
THAT'S THERE, BUT SHE'S LIKE,
"I'M NOT GONNA BRING IT OUT."
>> YEAH.
>> DALYA.
>> SHE COULD'VE HAMMED IT UP
A LITTLE BIT.
SHE HAD QUIET MOMENTS.
SHE'S NOT AN OVERACTOR.
>> I-I DO FEEL HERE THAT THERE--
LESS IS MORE,
AND THERE'S GREAT INTENSITY
IN JUST THAT SILENCE.
>> SHE HAS SUCH A MODERN FACE
TO ME...
>> YES,
>> AND, LIKE, A-A BEAUTIFUL,
LIKE, A MASK OF--ON THE WALL.
LIKE, JUST GORGEOUS ART.
>> MOLLY.
>> I THINK SHE PULLED IT OFF,
AND IT WASN'T JUST THE MAKEUP
AND THE HAIR AND THE DRESS
AND THE PEARLS.
THERE WAS A SENSE
OF THAT "MAD MEN"-IN-THE-OFFICE
BEING SEXY.
>> I THINK SHE DID GREAT
WHEN SHE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SHE'S ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT HAS PRESENCE.
BUT WHAT ELSE?
>> HAVE WE REACHED A DECISION?
>> WE DID.
I STILL NEED A COFFEE.
>> TEN BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
AND I ONLY HAVE NINE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE NINE PHOTOS
ARE SCREENGRABS
FROM YOUR COMMERCIAL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL IS
THE BEST COMMERCIAL PERFORMANCE.
I THINK IT'S OBVIOUS, KASIA.
COME ON DOWN.
YOU JUST MAY BE
ONE OF THE BEST CONTESTANTS
IN A COMMERCIAL
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME,
>> SO WHO IS RUNNER-UP
FOR BEST PERFORMANCE
IN A COMMERCIAL?
HANNAH.
CONGRATULATIONS, HANNAH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL...
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WORK IT.
WORK. YEAH.
>> MM.
>> WORK THE BOOTY.
YES! YES! YES! YES!
OH! OOPS! OOPS! OOPS! OOPS!
(laughter)
>> YES. YES!
AND YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP BOOTY SHAKER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL...
DALYA.
MONIQUE.
MOLLY.
MIKAELA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL...
BRITTANI.
>> SO YOU TAKE
SOME AMAZING PHOTOS,
BUT IN THIS COMMERCIAL,
YOU SHRUNK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WILL SARA AND ALEXANDRIA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> TWO BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE SCREENGRAB
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR HOME
HERE IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES,
PACK YOUR BAGS, AND GO HOME.
AND, SARA--
LOVELY, INTERESTING FACE.
THE KIND OF FACE,
THE KIND OF ENERGY,
THE KIND OF GIRL THAT I LOVE,
THAT I STARTED "TOP MODEL"
BECAUSE OF.
AN ORIGINAL.
BUT WHAT WASN'T ORIGINAL
WAS YOUR PERFORMANCE.
THERE WAS A LACK OF COMMITMENT
AND A LACK OF CONFIDENCE,
WHICH THE JUDGES SEE
FROM WEEK TO WEEK.
AND THEN WE HAVE ALEXANDRIA,
WHO DID A DECENT JOB
IN THE COMMERCIAL--
OR SHALL I SAY
AN INDECENTJOB.
IT WAS SEXY
LEANING TOWARDS SLEAZY.
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW
WHY YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BECAUSE THERE'S A PATTERN
DEVELOPING.
LAST WEEK,
THE STYLIST COMPLAINED.
THIS WEEK,
THE DIRECTOR SAID THE SAME.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> CONFIDENCE WINS, ALEXANDRIA.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> (whispers indistinctly)
NOW GO ON, GIRL.
>> IT'LL BE THE LAST TIME
THAT I TELL YOU
THAT YOU COULD POSSIBLY
BE GOING HOME
BECAUSE OF ATTITUDE.
>> IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I'M MAD AT YOU...
>> I KNOW. I'M SO SORRY.
>> 'CAUSE...
ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
I MEAN, LOOK AT YOU.
>> I WANNA HUG YOU!
>> BUT, OH, MY GOD.
YOU'RE SO AMAZING.
WHEN YOU BELIEVE
IN YOUR UNIQUE BEAUTY,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A SHOT
AT A MODELING CAREER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GOOD LUCK,
AND YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAD TROUBLE GETTING INTO
THE WHOLE PREMISE
OF THE COMMERCIAL, AND HONESTLY,
THAT WAS MY OWN ISSUE.
IF YOU'RE A MODEL,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE
TO GET INTO
WHATEVER THEY NEED YOU TO DO.
LIKE, I DON'T EVEN
NEED MY MOM HERE
TO SHAKE HER FINGER AT ME.
I'M SHAKING MY FINGER AT MYSELF.
I GOT THE LONG WALK.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GOING TO HEAVEN
OR SOMETHING.
WAVE GOOD-BYE!
(laughter)
>> IF I COULDN'T MUSTER
THE SEXUAL ENERGY
OR THE LITTLE COY THING GOING ON
THAT THEY NEEDED ME TO,
THEN--THEN I WASN'T
DOING MY JOB PROPERLY,
AND THAT'S MY OWN FAULT.
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.